[Music]
Lauren and Chris one of you is the voice
it came down to reigning champion Blake
Shelton's Lauren dusky versus Team
Alisha's Chris blue on Tuesday night's
season 12 finale of The Voice
[Applause]
Chris was the very last artist to be
picked in The Blind Auditions and went
on to win it all
Alicia gushed over her team's win after
the show
you'll be Blake I don't feel the shot
gentlemen you know it's been a great
dream of mine I gotta be honest it's a
great dream of mine to put a whooping on
Blake show and I couldn't wait for the
day when I could say Blake yeah this
season I've been so committed to the
voice Gwen Stefani made her final
appearance on the singing competition
show it's obvious there are some things
she's gonna miss you brought your chair
to dinner some people might even say
that I take my work home
I think win really needs to find some
outside interest outside interests a
garden I also love to meditate
[Music]
later in coming season 13 judge Miley
Cyrus performed an emotional rendition
of her new song Malibu
[Applause]
[Music]
here
you
skies
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
you
[Music]